hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the important topics that Kant is
going to explain to us in the preface to
his short work the prologomina to any
future metaphysics is the relationship
between that work and his earlier and
much longer work the critique of pure
reason is this supposed to be an
introduction to the critique we're
actually going to see no that's not
quite the case and the place that we
want to pick up is where he's talking
about David Hume and what Kant did with
hume's problem or objection or issue
that he was bringing up but we've
already talked about that a bit so we'll
pick up with him saying I tried first
whether hume's objection could not be
put into what's translated as a general
form but I'll give mine right so whether
it could be done in a universe reversal
way more than just a mere generality and
he said I soon found that the concept of
the connection of cause and effect was
by means no means the only concept by
which the understanding thinks the
connection of things ah priority how
things that we are cognizing
experiencing how are these things
connected together and can we abstract
this away from experience
and the answer is yes not only with
cause and effect but with a whole bunch
of other matters as well and so uh Khan
says I sought to ascertain their number
when I had done this starting from a
single principle I proceeded to the
deduction of these Concepts right
concepts are uh
and deduction is just a cognate there
this is a procedure that is working
through and then he says I was now
certain these were not derived from
experience but they rather sprang from
the pure
understanding and he says you know Hume
never really thought about doing this it
seemed impossible and it didn't occur to
anyone else
but this is you know a possible thing to
do it was the most difficult task ever
undertaken in the service of metaphysics
and uh he says I couldn't use
metaphysics to do this but I succeeded
in solving hume's problem not merely in
a particular case but with respect to
the whole the entire faculty of pure
reasons
so the entirety of this higher faculty
higher than the understanding that is
reason and so he says you know once I
did this I could actually determine the
entire sphere of pure reason completely
and from Universal principles in this is
very important it's boundaries it's
grenzen right and in its content it's in
Halt and he's going to use that term
grenzin a little bit later Kant is very
much about limits and setting boundaries
to how far we can go with things that's
part of what critical philosophy is
about and this is what we indeed find in
the critique of pure reason
so he's starting from a particular you
know but not completely uh particular
not single uh issue that Hume is is
Raising one of of a significant scope
and then he's going even further he's
he's taking a more radical approach to
it and that's what we get in the
critique of pure reason which is quite a
massive tone now Kant is going to point
something out at this point that's a
little bit humorous in some respects how
did people receive the critique of pure
reason
so as I fear that the working out of
hume's problem in its widest extent that
is in this book The critique of pure
reason it will fear as the problem
itself fared when first proposed who
first proposed it and
people didn't understand what Hume was
really getting at and they came up with
solutions that weren't real solutions to
this problem and so the critique of pure
reason is going to be misjudged
Earth island is uh judgment right by
Earth island is is another way of saying
that and unrichtig wrongly right
unrightly so it's going to be misjudged
why will it be misjudged because it's
going to be misunderstood and why is it
going to be misunderstood well
Kant does not have a very high opinion
of many of his fellow Scholars
misunderstood because men choose to skim
through the book and not to think
through it a disagreeable task because
the work is in fact dry obscure opposed
to all ordinary Notions and moreover
long-winded so he's engaging in a little
bit of self-criticism there but he's
also saying these these readers are lazy
too so they're not going to understand
what's going on in the critique of pure
reason and you know we do see in fact
criticisms of other people of his time
saying yeah this book isn't really that
that great and then he brings up two
complaints that could be made about the
critique of pure reason one set he
thinks are pretty groundless so somebody
might come along and say you know the
critique of pure reason is
um you know philosophers are going to
complain that it lacks popularity and
that's actually just a cognitive for
popularity
entertain attainments went to Halton you
know enjoyableness
people don't read the critique of pure
reason like they do a novel because of
the wonderful characters or anything
like that and also facility or we could
say ease
the kite
the you know
comfortableness of it it's a difficult
work it's a great philosophical text
so you know do you really expect it to
be put into a popular way and he says I
didn't expect to hear complaints from
philosophers when the existence of a
highly praised and indispensable
cognition in their kentness a knowledge
is at stake which can't be established
other than by the strictest rules of
scholarly Precision so if you're going
to complain that the book isn't an easy
book to read your complaint is off base
because there's no way you could do the
work in the critique of pure reason and
make it a fun book to to go along with
right that's the wrong kind of complaint
now Kant will also say that there is a
certain obscurity a Dunkel height
right to this this book so he's
conceding that and why is this well
because of the diffuseness the Vite
loythey kite of its plan diffuseness
maybe not the best word there in this
particular English translation
so ranging over a you know very wide
scope of matters matters by the way that
are all connected with each other as
he's going to say a little bit later
will tell us a pure reason is the sphere
so separate and self-contained we cannot
touch apart without affecting all the
rest so you know we have to do a big big
thick book to outline all of this stuff
and he says okay that's a legitimate
criticism this obscurity this difficulty
involved in it this book The prologomina
can help out with that and he says
that's the the goal of it
um as regards this obscurity uh owing to
which the principal points of the
investigation are easily lost sight of
this complaint is just and I intend to
remove it by the present prologomina the
read this ahead of time right
and then he's going to help specify what
the relationship is between these and he
tells it that that it is in fact a
preliminary uh a for ubergan to the
critique which is
a foundation right so he says the first
mentioned work the the critique which
discusses the pure faculty of reason and
its whole extent and Bounds will remain
the foundation the grundlaga to which
the prologometer as a preliminary
exercise refer that critique must exist
as a science systematic and complete as
to its smallest Parts before we can
think of letting metaphysics on the
scene so we don't just clear the
prologomina we actually have to go
through the first critique and then we
can do metaphysics after that and
interestingly just as a side note Kant
is going to talk about metaphysics in
his work he's not banishing it forever
there's even within the Practical
philosophy of metaphysics of morals
right which is a very important part of
his work
and he's going to say that he thinks
that he can
persuade the reader that the prologist
will persuade the reader that this
critique this critical philosophy which
is leading into metaphysics is a
perfectly new science of which no one
has uh even thought and
um
you know Hume himself didn't didn't
recognize this he talks about Hume uh
foundering on the shoals of skepticism
but the critique is actually setting out
for us the possibilities of a new
science and the prologomina can persuade
it can lead somebody to that now
although he calls it a preliminary to
the critique
um the translation can be a little bit
confusing because uh it's it's turning
verbs into nouns
and
Kant wants to say that the prologomina
is not a sketch for the here we go
although a mere sketch preceding the
critique of pure reason that's not what
the prologomina is why not because it
would be unintelligible unreliable and
useless but the prologomina is he says
more useful as a sequel it fault it
follows on the critique of pure reason
so it doesn't precede it for her gay and
go out in advance of it so you read this
first and then read the critique rather
they're doing complementary things and
you might actually read this afterwards
as indeed many of his contemporary
readers would be doing who have already
read the first critique now
interestingly again as a side note very
often when we are teaching Kant
the speculative or or you know pure
philosophy we will in fact have students
undergraduate students read the
prologomina first and then go on to the
first critique Kant is actually telling
us maybe that's not the best way to to
do things now the last thing that we
need to bring up is a contrast that he
also tells us and this is a very near
the end of the preface
he says that that work being completed I
offer here such a plan which is sketched
out after an analytical method Okay so
we've got this term analytic which plays
an important role in what's going to
come afterwards he's not using it in
exactly the same sense
this is referring to the mode of
presentation as we see when he tells us
that the critique of pure reason had to
be executed in the synthetical style now
the synthetical style the style there is
Leia art the way of teaching the mode of
presentation so we've got a difference
between what we we've got here in this
text and in the much larger critique and
what he says is that
executed in the synthetic style in order
that the science may present all its
articulations as the structure of a
peculiar cognitive faculty in their
natural combination so
in a way you can say that the synthetic
style is closer to
the matters that that's Kant is
investigating and then presenting to us
in the critique of pure reason whereas
the analytic style you're coming to it
afterwards and you're saying can I
present this in a an easier to digest
Manner and that's what the prologomina
is intended to do for all of us readers
so that is the relationship between
these two very important texts that are
part of the speculative critical
philosophy now we have a clear idea
where Kant is going with this and the
purpose of the prologomina as a work of
philosophy